LeBron I'm curious if you could walk us
through the day starts with Carmelo
Anthony someone who you were are very
close with in in your contemporary
announcing his retirement and then you
getting ready to play in a Western
Conference Finals game as sort of the
The Last Man Standing if you will from
that class what was that like for you
um
well I kind of knew the the announcement
was going to happen
um because I shot the video a week ago
that you guys seen today so
um people probably think I'm lying about
that too huh
um I shot that video like a week ago so
I already knew the announcement was
coming just didn't know which day but it
happened today and uh
but it's still Bittersweet obviously
that's
one of my best friends
um
you know when I got into this even
before I got to this league I mean
when we have so many moments when we're
in high school from competing against
each other to um
you know
you know sitting outside of a hotel room
you know at two or three o'clock in the
morning on the steps of a hotel and just
talking about
our journey up until where we were 17 I
was 16 he was 17 and
what we could possibly do going forward
what we could possibly do for our
mothers what we could possibly do for
our families if we just continue to stay
focused
uh
I believe we just we was a driving force
for one another we were
locked at the hip since high school and
then you guys saw that once we got into
the NBA and
um
he was always a motor factor for me I've
been in the Western Conference I was in
the East
so I will play our games you know and
then I would rush home to my Rush on
downtown Cleveland where I had like an
apartment my first two years in the in
the league and Russia turned to the
Nuggets games on you know and and watch
mellow play
all the way to the point where we didn't
make the playoffs my first year I ended
I was in Denver for his first playoff
game
um you can look that up too just in case
you think I'm lying about that too
um
so
definitely just a Bittersweet moment
today to to see one of my great friends
um
I'll never like to say call it quits I
mean just to say that
you know
amazing run amazing accomplishment
an amazing career
and uh
you know we just we always will be
joined at the hip no matter what